mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour en cette veille du 14 juillet
une bonne nouvelle pour commencer ce
journal la météo est optimiste
puisqu'elle prévoit sur l'ensemble du
pays
un bot au temps chaud et ensoleillé beau
temps qui se poursuivra également demain
c'est donc il faut l'espérer sous un
soleil radieux que demain à partir de 9h
30 se déroulera sur les champs elysées
le traditionnel défilé des troupes
quelques chiffres pour ce défilé dix
mille hommes 650 véhicules et un peu
plus de 160 avions et hélicoptères
participeront à cette grande parade du
14 juillet on a répété et on répète
encore ce défilé sur une photographie
par exemple eh bien vous allez découvrir
les trois régiments d'infanterie de
marine
lors d'une ultime mise au point mise au
point effectuée sur le circuit
automobile du mans répétition également
pour les légionnaires qui eux
s'entraînent dans le bois de vincennes
on met également la dernière main aux
balles qui vous accueilleront à partir
de ce soir les pompiers de la caserne
malheur tout à côté de la télévision
seront fin prêts à vous le voyez pour
vous pour pouvoir vous accueillir
enfin ce soir aussi des feux d'artifice
un peu partout en france
mais un point quand même à signaler les
parisiens devront attendre demain soir
pour voir les feux d'artifice dans la
capitale
ces feux d'artifice ils seront au nombre
de ceux à l'étranger c'est l'irlande
aujourd'hui encore qui va retenir
l'attention des observateurs les
protestants vous le savez célèbre
aujourd'hui le 204e 20e anniversaire de
la bataille de la bonne
une bataille qu'ils ont gagné contre les
catholiques
plus de cent mille personnes vont
défiler aujourd'hui dans les rues de
belfast et dans toute l'irlande du nord
les orangistes sont bien décidés à fêter
cet événement comme il se doit pour
éviter des erreurs qui peuvent toujours
se produire entre les protestants et les
catholiques 7000 soldats et 4000
policiers sont sur le pied de guerre
depuis bientôt quarante huit heures hier
dimanche par exemple il ya eu quelques
défilés de protestants quelques
manifestations protestante
mais ces manifestations se sont
déroulées dans le plus grand calme
un calme jugé inquiétant par les
officiers de l'armée britannique
dépêchée en toute hâte et en renfort en
irlande du nord pourquoi ce déploiement
de force
pourquoi cette inquiétude de part et
d'autre et bien parce que l'on redoute
vous
en douter des affrontements semblables à
ceux qui avaient endeuillé l'année
dernière l'irlande d'une inquiétude en
irlande
inquiétude également aux états unis à la
suite des incidents qui se sont produits
la nuit dernière dans un certain nombre
de grandes villes jugées plutôt des
incidents qui ont opposé parfois assez
violemment il faut le dire les forces de
l'ordre et les populations noires de
sébile l'état d'urgence et le couvre-feu
de premières mesures ont été institués à
michigan city dans l'indiana a new
bedford dans le massachusetts et ensuite
à highland park dans le michigan
enfin troisième point chaud de cette
actualité internationale
le moyen-orient avec sur toutes les
frontières d'israël nous allons faire le
point sur une carte des combats des
accrochages et des attentes
premier point le canal de suez cette
nuit deux unités égyptienne franchissent
le canal et attaque des positions
israéliennes dans la région dès le
deuxième point nous remontons cette fois
sur la frontière israélo-jordanienne
près de la vallée de bessan là c'est une
unité de l'armée israélienne qui
traverse le jourdain et qui attaque un
avant poste de l'armée jordanienne près
du kibboutz de yardeni enfin à quelques
kilomètres de la frontière libanaise
c'est tout à fait au nord sur cette
carte près de saint jean d'âcre un
commando palestinien attaques à la
roquettes à partir du territoire
libanais un village de vacances n'a rien
fort heureusement il n'ya pas eu de
victime à la suite de cette attaque
et puis le moyen-orient il faut le
signaler aussi sur le plan diplomatique
une interview de monsieur joseph cisco
le spécialiste des questions du
moyen-orient au département d'état
américain monsieur cisco dans une
interview a cependant refusé de
confirmer des informations qui avaient
donné notre confrère newsweek
informations selon lesquelles le
président nixon serait enclin à livrer
de nouveaux appareils de combat à israël
en france
nous abordons maintenant l'actualité
française l'actualité politique est en
sommeil en cette veille de 14 juillet
mais une actualité qui sera quand même
marqué par les obsèques cet après midi à
barbezieux en charente de l'ancien
président du conseil monsieur félix
gaillard l'actuel premier ministre
monsieur jacques chaban delmas sera
présent cet après midi à barbezieux
hier soir la dépouille mortelle de
l'ancien président du conseil était
arrivé à barbezieux
barbezieux la gentilhommière de monsieur
félix gaillard
c'était hier soir vers 19h15 que la
voiture transportant le corps de
l'ancien président du conseil s'est
rangée contre la maison depuis plusieurs
heures une foule recueillie attendait
discrètement près de la demeure des amis
plusieurs personnalités étaient auprès
des membres de la famille lorsque le
cercueil recouvert d'un drap violet fut
déposée dans le salon c'est là
aujourd'hui la population de barbezieux
devait venir rendre un dernier hommage à
l'homme politique disparu
un homme politique doit d'une telle
personnalité qu'il jouissait d'une
estime général la famille gaillard est
originaire de la chaise une petite
localité à une dizaine de kilomètres de
barbezieux c'est dans le cimetière de ce
village que se trouve le caveau familial
c'est ici à côté de son grand père et de
son père que le président félix gaillard
reposera désormais après l'ultime
hommage de ses nombreux amis des
personnalités dans monsieur jacques
chaban-delmas premier ministre je
voulais dit en ouvrant ce journal la
météo a prévu jusqu'à la fin de ce très
long week-end du 14 juillet du soleil et
de la chaleur sur l'ensemble du pays est
de l'avis même de tous les spécialistes
ce week-end de 14 juillet eh bien c'est
le plus beau week end aux laines il n'y
a jamais eu autant de voitures sur les
routes
si vous avez pris votre voiture vous
avez pu vous en apercevoir 15% dit on de
plus que l'année dernière à pareille
époque
malheureusement cette augmentation de la
circulation a eu des conséquences bien
sûr quant aux accidents main sur un
document que vous allez voir
c'était à la roche sur yon hier en
vendée un accident de la route
cinq personnes périssent carbonisés et
puis une dépêche qui vient de me
parvenir qui nous donne d'appel agence
france presse le bilan des accidents de
la route seulement pour samedi et
dimanche
103 morts et 8 145 blessés dont 370
grièvement at assez excitant de la route
il faut ajouter aussi des accidents dus
aux vacances des accidents comme les
noyades par exemple elle temps de tester
très nombreuses en ce week-end puisqu'il
a fait très chaud
et puis aussi
des accidents de monter à l'étranger les
autorités roumaines et les autorités
péruviennes ont enfin dressé le bilan
presque définitif des deux catastrophes
qui ont endeuillé ces dernières semaines
la roumanie avec des inondations et le
pérou avec le tremblement de terre du 31
mai dernier
vous allez le voir avec stéphane paoli
c'est un bilan extrêmement lourd en
roumanie
166 personnes ont péri quatorze autres
ont été portées disparues les
inondations ont emporté plus de 15000 km
de voies ferrées et détruit 6700 km de
routes pour l'agriculture le bilan est
aussi dramatique puisque sept mille
hectares de céréales ont été envahies
par les eaux 45 maisons ainsi que 20000
construction dirait diverses des usines
notamment ont été totalement détruites
et près de 15000 villes ou villages ont
tué souffrir de ces inondations au pérou
le tremblement de terre du 31 mai
dernier a ravagé une zone de près de
cent mille kilomètres carrés faisant 1
million 700 mille sinistrés et causant
des dégâts estimés à plus de 500
millions de dollars plus de cent
cinquante mille maisons ont été
détruites et il faudra deux ans pour
redonner à cette région du pérou un
semblant de vie économique
nous changeons totalement du sujet
puisque vous allez pouvoir le constater
nous allons ouvrir maintenant une page
appelée si vous voulez les petits échos
de la vie internationale et à la
première page de ces petits échos de la
vie internationale un navigateur qu'il
faut féliciter torrio dalle en effet
après 56 jours de traversée le
navigateur norvégien et son équipage
sont arrivés hier à la barbade michel
toulouse la preuve est faite des
navigateurs égyptiens ont pu découvrir
l'amérique bien avant christophe colomb
et fonder les civilisations d'amérique
du film thor heyerdahl sur son radeau
construit en papyrus comme les bateaux
égyptiens a pu affronter traverser
l'atlantique
il est arrivé ce matin la barbade aux
antilles après une traversée de 56 jours
le rade avait quitté sa fille au maroc
le 17 mai dernier
nous voyons le bateau au cours de son
voyage vers l'amérique la coke en
papyrus et imbibés d'eau mais le radeau
encore une flottaison satisfaisante
il bat pavillon des nations unies et sa
cabine de huit mètres sur deux est une
petite reproduction de l'onu puisque
huit hommes de huit nationalités
différentes y d'ensemble à bord tout
s'est très bien passé le médecin de bord
un soviétique n'a eu qu'à soigner les
deux premiers jours les hommes atteints
de mal de mer
pour thor heyerdahl c'était la deuxième
tentative son premier bâton papyrus que
nous voyons ici avait coulé au large de
la barbade
une façon comme une autre vous le voyez
de passer des vacances sur leur autre
façon peut-être de passer des vacances à
les regarder le passage du tour de
france aujourd'hui 17e étape toulouse
saint gaudens 190 km et au bout de
l'étape bien sûr les pires et je ne sais
pas si hier vous vous promeniez dans le
loir-et-cher très exactement du côté de
ville chose toujours est il que vous
avez peut-être été surpris si vous étiez
ville chauvière de voir autant de choses
hier en effet les plus belles calvitie
de france s'étaient donné rendez-vous
pour quoi et bien pour l'élection du
plus beau chauffe de france regardez
il chauffe 250 habitants habituellement
autant de cheveux qu'ailleurs le d'hier
ville chaud sous le soleil brillait de
mille feux
shaw venus de tous les coins de france
mais aussi chauve sans frontières tous
au préalable c'est en arracher le
dernier choc
l'épreuve finale était la plus redoutée
passage de la brosse à rebrousse poil
contrôle du désert à la loupe calcul au
cm de la surface gagner sur la forêt
premier un choc d'orléans 944 cm de
surface garant pic poli n'est pas chauve
qui peut vous avez peut-être reconnu
philippe gildas france vérité avant de
passer à notre page magazine j'aurais
donné deux informations générales la
première la chambre des flagrants délits
d'aix-en-provence a condamné ce matin
joseph boulbès le frère d'alex goude
baisse à 4 mois de prison avec sursis
pour outrage à magistrat vous savez
qu'il ya vu un incident lors de lorsque
la cour d'aix-en-provence avait rendu
son verdict et puis toujours pour le
procès de pury coeur nous apprenons que
arlette boulbès gaston costera ses
sauveurs padovani les trois accusés
d'aix-en-provence
eh bien ces trois accusés ont demandé
aujourd'hui leur pourvoi en cassation
voilà à vous la parole pour cette page
magazine très bien et bien vous savez
que les formules de vacances multiplient
et se diversifient d'année en année la
voici comment des jeunes ce sont des
scouts de france ont choisi de passer
leurs vacances en aveyron un reportage
de jean pierre delgado
ils soient scouts ou tout simplement
indépendants certains jeunes ont
semble-t-il trouvé la solution à leurs
vacances
en voici un exemple avec un groupe de
scouts de la région parisienne
ces vacances sont vraiment les leurs
pour descendre l'aveyron en bateau ils
ont travaillé pour avoir de l'argent ils
ont vendu de vieux journaux repeint des
appartements vendus du muguet et bien
d'autres choses encore et puis comme il
voulait fabriquer eux mêmes leurs
bateaux ils ont suivi un stage dans une
usine de fabrication place le résultat
il est là sous vos pieds
grâce à leur acharnement elles sont
parties même si pendant cinq mois ils
ont travaillé à l'est le barracuda
récompenses et avery a préparé ce camp
légèrement avant noël c'est donc à peu
près cinq mois que l'on est sur cette
entreprise cinq mois se demande quand
même beaucoup de deux heures de libre
est-ce que ça se passe pour vous enfin
un peu pour chacun de vous moi ce que
vous réussissez à vous libérer pour
préparer parce que je crois que vous
avez fabriqué les bateaux vous a préparé
les itinéraires vous a préparé un peu
tout instinct bien que ça demande une
certaine organisation personnelle parce
qu'évidemment on fait ça pendant
longtemps loisirs c'est à dire le jeu
dimanche je le dimanche jeudi ou le soir
en semaine
le meilleur exemple d'organisation du
travail c'est 25 jeunes nous le montre
malgré leur activité très prenante ils
ont réussi l'exploit de tout ce que sir
leurs examens de fin d'année
descendre l'aveyron en bateau retapé un
vieux château visite est un pays
étranger autant d'activités qui sont à
la disposition de tous si vous n'avez
pas d'idées pour vos vacances et pour
combler vos heures de loisirs pendant la
nuit
eh bien les promenades sous le soleil
cela donne soif c'est bien connu
et si vous n'avez pas envie de boire de
l'eau voici quelques suggestions de
boissons fraîches pour l'été et comme
nous prenions grand soin de votre santé
ce sont des poissons non alcoolisées par
catherine alexandre pour un cocktail un
après midi ensoleillé une soirée chaude
quelques suggestions de boissons
fraîches et non alcoolisées du thé glacé
par exemple pour 6 personnes verser dans
chaque verre une cuillérée à soupe de
sucre
mouiller avec très peu de bouillante
remuez vous obtiendrez un sirop de sucre
qui se mélangera parfaitement au thé
dans une théière ébouillanté météo temps
deux cuillérées à café de thé que de
convives pour éviter qu'ils ne se
forment des dépôts au moment où le vert
sur la glace il est préférable de mettre
plus de thé et de laisser infuser moins
longtemps que pour interdite n'est versé
1 litre d'eau bouillante qui doit être
retiré du feu dès le premier bouillon et
laisser infuser 5 minutes exactement
disposer cinq ou six glaçons dans chaque
verre et versez dessus le thé brûlant
tournée
et servez les glaçons à demi fond qu un
demi verre de jus d'ananas une bouteille
de jus de pomme 3 oranges et un citron
pressé pour un cocktail de jus de pomme
mais d une douzaine de glaçons dans un
broc un jus de fruit
ajouter le jus d'ananas laurange
c'est trop
et un litre de jus de pomme
versez 2 cuillérées à soupe de sucre et
remuer
à servir très glacée toujours pour 6
personnes un cocktail au jus de raisin
couper une range en rondelles pressez le
jus 2 à 2 3 4 citrons ajouté celui de
deux oranges
mettez les rondelles d'orange dans la
cruche pour parfumer ajouté un morceau
de cannelle verser le mélange orange
citron puis
le litre de jus de raisin 3 cuillerées à
soupe de sucre tournée et servez sans
attendre
un verre de sirop de framboise et une
boîte de pamplemousse dans une carafe
mélanger un verre de sirop de framboise
et une boîte de jus de pamplemousse
ou une bouteille
une
versez la quantité désirée dans chaque
verre est complétée avec de l'eau
gazeuse à volonté
ajoutez quelques glaçons une bouteille
de jus d'ananas une bouteille d'abricots
pour un cocktail désigné dans un pichet
mélanger le jus d'ananas au jus
d'abricot
ajoutez une demi bouteille d'eau mettez
une heure au réfrigérateur pour le
service plonger le bord du verre dans un
centimètre d'eau roulée dans le sucre
garnissez d'une rondelles d'orange et
servez
bien si le chemin de vos vacances
passent par dieppe
arrêtez vous et ne manquez surtout pas
de visiter le musée de thiès où l'on
peut compter en particulier quelques
très importantes pièces d'ivoire car en
effet dieppe est la patrie d ivoire y
est depuis des siècles ce sont
d'authentiqués artistes qui sculptent
qui travaillent
l'ivoire et voici à ce sujet un
reportage de notre station de rouen
dieppe
trente mille habitants la doyenne des
stations climatique française un port
actif et pittoresque une ville animée et
riche d'un passé que le touriste peut
retrouver au pollet à saint jacques au
vieux château du 15e siècle ce bazar
château comporte aussi un musée le
château d'un musée depuis 1923
placez les collections du musée
municipal de dieppe
si bien qu'on appelle le château musée
ces normes ias et dans certaines
vitrines de ce musée
on y trouve d ivoire alors on parlera
pas spécialement d ivoire de flamber si
vous voulez mais oui puisque d'abord
c'est la collection la plus importante
du musée collection qui a été constituée
essentiellement avec les témoins du
travail des ivoiriens dieppois depuis le
16e siècle puisque notre époque
alors pourquoi d ivoire indien vous
savez ça c'est une histoire tout à fait
logique dans le déroulement de ce qui
s'est passé à dieppe depuis les origines
les dieppois c'était le grand navigateur
on dit que les navigateurs dieppois ont
découvert les côtes de guinée au 14e
siècle
en tout cas on importait d'ivoire à
dieppe ils sont depuis le 16e siècle au
moins
et comme on la porte est dédié pour
l'infini par le travail et dans les
pièces que
vous avez ne trouvant des bateaux parlez
nous un petit peu de ces bateaux est-ce
que vous avez des pièces une information
sur ces chaleurs il ya un très bon
bateau qui était comme pièce de
démonstration dans la vitrine d'un
atelier d'ivoire y est c'est le plus
beau bateau de la collection qui est
fait entièrement d'ivoire qui a tous ses
voiles en croire même ses cordages il y
en a un autre par contre qui n'est
peut-être pas le dieppois de l'origine
mais qui a été fait par des marins le
prisonnier à bord des comptes en anglais
pendant les violences
on peut parler de bâtiment peut parler
aussi de boussole wee cc boussole qui
n'était peut-être pas seulement des
instruments de navigation et qui était
une spécialité de la base des cadrans et
boussole que fabriquer les blue les
sénégal au xviie siècle
qui sont ces objets très précis et très
précieux en même temps décorez de
gravure extrêmement fine et qui
permettait de trouver énormément de
choses en particulier leurs deux jours
et deux nuits en s'orientant sur la lune
sur les étoiles sur le soleil des
dessins très différent d'ailleurs on
retrouve des thèmes religieux
on trouve un peu de tout il est probable
que c'était des travaux qu'on vous êtes
à la commande
on y trouve aussi des armoiries vous
avez reconstituer ici au musée un petit
atelier d'ivoire y est oui j'ai pu
trouver cent des eaux trop de
difficultés grâce à la compréhension
d'un certain nombre de pieds poings la
plupart des outils qui servait et pour
faire le travail que les gens voient
dans la vitrine et on voit cet atelier
d'ailleurs après avoir vu des objets et
les visiteurs n'en semble que plus
surpris de voir constater la finesse
avec laquelle
et tfc ces choses très détaillée de
l'attendu tsl dentelle d'ivoire et de
votre résultat qu'on pouvait obtenir
avec des outils apparemment très gros ce
qui ressemble un petit peu d'ailleurs à
des outils de menuisier donc il semble
surtout à des outils d'orfèvre
d'ailleurs il ya délit non comme la
grêle lequan la cheville qui sont
analogues au nom des métiers dans
lesquels travaille le métal
on travaillait au temps presque lowe's
de mouton ou que l'ivoire d'éléphant
on travaille est aussi la date d'achat
l'os de baleines et en même temps qu'il
voir toutes sortes d'autres matières on
dit d'ailleurs sur un prospectus qui
avait été édité par j'entre une belle
tête ou jean antoine même fait au xviiie
siècle pour dit il travaillait l'os la
corne l'ivoire la noix de coco l'anacr
et et d'autres matières encore on peut
reprocher aux ivoiriens dieppois re
général d'être essentiellement des
artisans très habile et qui ont inventé
très peu sachant et en moins
répétez parfaitement de toujours le même
formule l'un d'entre eux par contre
pierre guillon qui est à travailler au
19e siècle a trouvé une expression
personnelle a eu quelque chose à dire et
a traduit dans ces ivoires peut aussi
bien dans ses bois sculpté eu dans ses
peintures la misère profonde dans
laquelle il était né dans laquelle il
avait il avait eu toute une partie de sa
vie je crois que diem est vraiment la
seule le seul centre important du
travail de l'ivoire on a travaillé
l'ivoire à roissy mais la plupart du
temps ce sont des ivoiriens
des fois qu'ils sont venus s'installer
rarement effet eu seulement à la fameuse
7e siècle dans tout cet été ils vont
pourra donc visité ce musée quinze jours
tous les jours le musée de dieppe est
ouvert tous les jours du 15 juin au 15
septembre de faire au delà qu'après
qu'un seul point télé midi s'achève
ainsi je ne sais que vous souhaiter
bonne fin de week end bombal du xiii du
14 juillet en tout cas amusez vous bien
toute l'équipe de télé midi vous
souhaite une très bonne journée au
revoir
m